with whatever money you have for
marketing you must squeeze it and it
must work unbelievably hard to make the
thing happen you can't create growth
without new customers or without having
such a great service that you create
word of mouth and we must win on
relevance not just on our subjective
opinions of brand and we must do it at
scale so what I would do today is I
would produce as much content as humanly
possible on Tick Tock Facebook Instagram
YouTube Snapchat Pinterest at scale at
the lowest cost possible which is not at
the expense of the quality of the
content and I would do that and then
when I would get the signals Quantum
qual signals I would then amplify true
consumer insights into more meaningful
and that is the model that I believe in